maybe a [ __ ] game Guitar Hero I don't
even know it's probably still a thing a
video game where you could play as a
good god it was the it was the worst
stupidest [ __ ] video game I've ever
seen I mean hitting literally all you
were doing was hitting a button when a
thing told you to hit the button play
the real guitar some people were so good
it's just learn the real guitar get pus
god these door cast [ __ ]
playing guitar I did a tweet what was it
you know what sucked that video game
Guitar Hero if you played that and we're
good at it you were a piece of [ __ ]
person and it got 20,000 likes okay now
I didn't expect that and then I wrote it
is it is just like play the real guitar
instead it's an actual skill and it
leads to more [ __ ] I don't like the
games were you got to hit a button when
it says hit a button and that's that's
all Guitar Hero is it's just really fast
and colorful and it's really [ __ ]
stupid and people were so good at it and
that's dumb because play the real good
but people were so good at it and not
good at the guitar and didn't know how
to play the guitar that's ridiculous and
then so many people were like oh you
just weren't good at it yeah no [ __ ] Oh
black better pam-i-am
I think that was on it was that on it
this is it basically what it is huh but
so fast boom boom boom boom boom boom
you can't dork central dorks
get good at the guitar to become cool
you're doing the dorky version of what a
dork does that's how [ __ ] sad your
life is if you're good at guitar hero a
dork is like how do I get checks to get
pay attention to me and then someone
created a guitar and now you've got
these heroin-chic tattooed up badass
[ __ ] that can play really well
and and get chicks and that's awesome
they figured out a skill but you're
doing what the dorky fake version of
what a dork
does do the real thing imagine buying
that little bitch-ass guitar imagine
going and picking that up and then it
was like rock band hero where you had a
[ __ ] guitar and then drums and then a
guy with a [ __ ] bass in an AHA a
harmonica it's like yeah how the house
is a [ __ ] recording studio that
doesn't record [ __ ] and instead of
actual instruments you got toys look at
these dorky-ass drums that you can get
for [ __ ] rock band ones red and
yellow and blue and green
imagine if rock band was around in the
80s how many non musicians there would
be that our musicians now like Phil
Collins maybe wouldn't have existed
because he would have just been like no
I just like to play [ __ ] hail to the
Queen on expand now I don't know [ __ ]
I didn't mic Genesis the group it's too
busy in me room pressing red when a TV
told me to press red there's probably so
many people not making bad music now
because they've just got hooked on
guitar hero Thank You Guitar Hero Thank
You rock band